Modern Warfare 2 multiplayer launchers
with some high highs and low lows Phil
Spencer talks more about Call of Duty
exclusivity and EA expands its upcoming
Marvel gaming lineup all this on today's
Gamespot news
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 was just
released on Friday and it had a massive
launch on PlayStation the company has
announced that Modern Warfare 2 has
become the quote biggest PlayStation
store launch of all time for the Call of
Duty Series this includes both
pre-orders and day one sales Sony said
the game is seemingly performing well on
other platforms too of course as Modern
Warfare 2 ranks number one on the Xbox
best seller list and is topping the
charts on PC via steam as well something
else that should come as no surprise is
that the game has had its fair share of
issues since releasing also developer
Infinity Ward has had to disable
attachment tuning a new feature that
allowed players to more precisely tweak
their weapons due to game crashes
pinging is also currently unavailable in
the game as a bug would lead to players
being permanently pinged and their
location highlighted through a match if
an opponent were to Ping them as their
death anime played out we on the
Gamespot team ourselves have experienced
some of these issues in additions to a
bunch of other ones I myself was in the
middle of tuning one of my attachments
until I backed out and poof my tuning
was gone I also was unable to load up
the campaign when multiplayer dropped
without restarting the mission I was
very close to beating and I also had a
price of five thousand dollars attached
to all my weapons before starting a
match our supervising producer Aaron
Sampson had random crashes video
producer Jake Deca had issues
[Music]
hopefully Activision is able to address
these issues with an upcoming patch soon
for more info on everything Modern
Warfare 2 check out our plethora of
videos on the game here at Gamespot with
Modern Warfare 2 having its biggest
launch for the series ever on the
PlayStation Store Sony is probably happy
that Phil Spencer doubled down on Xbox's
commitment to keeping the franchise on
the platform if the Activision deal goes
through quote as long as there is a
Playstation out there to ship to our
intent is that we continue to ship Call
of Duty on PlayStation says Spencer in
an interview on the same brain podcast
while Spencer has previously committed
to continuing to release Call of Duty on
Playstation this is the clearest
indication that that commitment exists
Beyond a temporary deal that Activision
has made with Sony in the foreseeable
future that wasn't the only interesting
tidbit of information to come out from
Spencer on the podcast the head of
Microsoft gaming also stated that it had
been too long since Xbox has had a
triple A first party launch he went on
to note that 2023 is lining up to be a
big year for the Studio's output and
that those game schedules are no longer
being affected by complications due to
covid another company ramping up its
releases after a fairly quiet year is
Electronic Arts announcing that its deal
with Marvel will result in three games
so far only an Iron Man game has been
revealed which is being developed by
Dead Space remake Studio EA motive still
in a very early phase of development EA
motive says that it is aimed to create
an authentic Marvel experience starring
the armored Avenger and will reportedly
begin play testing this week as part of
some early fine tuning for the game one
of the other EA Marvel titles is rumored
to be a standalone open world Black
Panther game not to be confused with Amy
Hennig and Sky Dancers black panther
Captain America Team Up game set during
World War 2 code named project rainia
the title will likely be coming out of
EA's new seattle-based studio helmed by
Kevin Stevens who previously led the
charge on the Middle Earth Shadow of
Mordor and Shadow of War games no
details or rumors yet on what the third
collaborative experience between Marvel
and EA could be and that is it for
today's Gamespot news how has your
launch weekend for Modern Warfare 2 been
what would you like EA and Marvel's
third title to be let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow on Gamespot news
[Music]